chaos bloodshed and fury in rio de
janeiro's el mal complex
[Applause]
[Music]
bodies bundled onto makeshift stretchers
into cars whatever people would find
others strewn onto the streets along
with bullet shells
the police say bum you're going to die
now bum's going to die but it could be
his son right it could be his son a
worker but the people from the favela
don't have a voice
this is the aftermath of a large-scale
police raid on a complex of rio's slums
known as favelas
brazilian media published video of
helicopters firing into the region
[Applause]
and one of exchange of fire from the
ground
there armored vehicles forced their way
through the labyrinth of alleyways
some 400 officers were involved in the
operation
police say they acted in self-defense
i would have preferred for them not to
react and for us to arrest the 14 or 15
people who would have faced justice
unfortunately they chose to react and
attacked the police officers
brazilian president jaya bolsonaro has
long favored heavy-handed police tactics
crime and gangs are growing in this area
and the police find it difficult to
fight these criminals it's similar to
when we watch cowboy movies in the past
whenever someone committed the crime in
the us and ran away
the public defender's office says there
are many signs of human rights
violations
[Applause]
most the victims are accused of being
gang members police say they robbed
banks stole cars and were planning
attacks on rival favelas
even if he was a criminal this is wrong
he has to be arrested are you going to
kill are you going to kill
what the police describe as an operation
locals are calling a massacre
saying the punishment doesn't fit the
crimes
al jazeera